and we are live
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movies Channel with Matthew
hello Matthew
and
Young Harris a young American way over
there but in Italy yeah he's actually
only down the road from us here in
Europe
but good morning good afternoon and good
the hell even in wherever the hell you
are in the world
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
right so this week we thought we would
do a little bit of a video but we would
have a link back on 2022 and we would
basically review it and just make sure
that we are actually live because nobody
is watching
uh I I just typed in howdy all group
chat so we should be live I believe
excellent okay
we're good good all good you never quite
know
um but yeah we're gonna review 2022
we're going to talk about what we loved
what we maybe didn't love so much what
surprised us and what you know we're
desperate for more of so
um first of all we we always do our
little bit at the start what have you
been watching this week chaps because I
gotta say there ain't a lot on at the
moment
um but I am going to throw my first
being in the Hat of what 2022 this year
that I have absolutely adored and can't
wait for more of and or and episode 11
was on this yeah it also surprised me
because
um Star Wars TV shows are bloody
brilliant and I'm not the biggest Star
Wars fan
but
um so that's that's the main thing I've
probably watched this this week what
about you guys
you wanna go man
oh uh I mean well I've been traveling so
I haven't watched as much as usual but
I've probably watched a solid third of a
season of Stargate sg1 just because
SGA Atlantis is not available yet in on
Prime in Italy apparently so I've just
been going through sg1 but I haven't I'm
trying to keep it well paced so I don't
like overlap you know uh besides that I
watched the new Andor episode and then I
saw black panther of course last week
but we talked about that last Sunday yes
we don't have to rehash that Nightmare
how about you
the owners watched this week uh are
finished manifest
the 10 episodes that I've been released
so far
kind of there's there's been surprises
there's been some Revelations and it is
very biblical like I said last week
um
it's kind of disappointing
this is the show I just said you mate I
moved from very early on this is going
to be disappointing because they built
it up way too much
it was a bit like lost it was always
going to be disappointing but
we were talking I was talking to my
missus about it after we'd we'd finished
watching it and uh like I'm not excited
to watch the next episode but I want to
watch it because I want to know what
happens I just need closure I just need
to know how it ends but every episode it
ends and I'm just like well that was
stupid why the hell did that happen
know like oh it's it's it is the most
disappointing show I've watched this
year
before we get stuck in them right have
you ever got become so invested in the
TV show that you continue to watch it
even though you got to a point where you
couldn't remember why you mean the
entire arrowverse
yeah yeah
yes the entire arrowverse I've I I was
watching The Flash because that's what
that's the one I started with
after season like three it just got so
ridiculous and so [ __ ] stupid I I
love the flash it's my favorite
oh my God like it's the the next season
that comes out it's the final one and
I'm so happy it's the final one because
I'm gonna watch it because it's the
flash I want to be disappointed anymore
I loved the arrowverse when it started
and I was one of those people that would
be like watching
Legends of Tomorrow the flash Arrow
Supergirl yada yada back and forth back
and forth by Supergirl season 2 by Arrow
season whatever the hell it was and and
Flash whatever season it was and I don't
know what happened to Jay but uh but
legends of tomorrows too it's just all
of it went so bad
we've got audio at least
Arrow was amazing up until
then
four I think for the season with
Prometheus that the like that was that
was the last good one not Prometheus not
Prometheus that was season one
um oh that bloke uh Adrian Adrian
Adrian Brody Adrian uh Adrian uh uh
Chase Adrian Chase
what's the character that's not Guardian
it's obviously that's John diggle uh
I think
um no no I got it I got this um I just
had it in my head it's
oh come on oh he was no he was
Prometheus yeah
he's Prometheus but he was also
vigilante right didn't he play vigilante
yes yes okay obviously vigilante towards
the beginning and then he came out to be
yeah anyway up until season it was
fantastic and yeah it just got
completely I didn't I never ended up
finishing Arrow
because I got so bored of it
yeah and I never watched the final
season I almost did just because they
did their whole crisis on infinite
Earths but I I just kind of I realized
how many episodes of TV I had to watch
prior to watching crisis on infinite
Earths and I was like I I can't do it
I'm not doing this yeah Legends of
tomorrow was good up and up until the
point I think uh in the season with
reverse flash
after that it got really awful
so I think it was season two maybe
season three
essentially reverse flash was in it with
uh when John Barrowman's character
Damien dark and
someone else I can't remember who but
it was so it was really good up until
the up and up until after that
yeah no I thought their best season when
snart died at the end of it and that was
just that was really well done actually
yeah
oh by the way I disappeared because I
made the error of once you set yourself
up to go on a live stream don't touch
anything and I I touched something
things
I won't touch my audience my audio
rubbish as well
oh yeah it's defaulted so my everything
reset
hey there's that beautiful voice right
there everything reset so everything
turned off all I did just move my
microphone
anything and you go live God damn it
um yeah um I watched the first couple of
episodes of Heroes of tomorrow or
whatever it's called and I realized very
quickly well that's not Iron Man and
turn it off
um
um no it's Superman
um
I I stopped watching arrowro about four
seasons in and see the thing you know
a brave man shouldn't be afraid of the
weather you know but a wise man knows
when to getting out of the rain
so if it's not very good anymore just
stop watching it
is the point of that little metaphor but
you know I start watching but I tell you
what I'm invested now yeah
um I think a big one for me was um bones
do you watch Bones a few years ago I
watched that all the way to the end but
after about season six I was just like I
don't know why I'm still watching this
show but I was also half expecting
something to happen and it didn't
um
did you ever watch scrubs
yeah
yeah
I watched that all the way through until
the finale and I wish I didn't
yeah because it was really it was so it
was really good in the beginning and the
final season and then I think there was
another season when they were like
residents or they had interns or
whatever
it was just awful it got serious I got a
bit of pretend asked I thought it was a
very funny anymore but anyway let's go
back to the point of the show today is
we're going to be talking about 2022
what we've enjoyed so first of all I'm
just going to ask you the question what
what is the TV show movie that surprised
you most this year
for me the TV show that surprised me the
most because I didn't I went into it not
knowing anything about it
uh it was Sandman
I absolutely loved Sandman and I didn't
think I I saw a trailer of it and I
thought it was a bit
I don't know it didn't look that good
from the trailer
so I went I went into it because it was
number one on Netflix I thought I'll
give it a go and I binged it in about
two days it was I loved it absolutely
loved it for me I think what I've put
there because I've seen sandman's on my
list and that's my number one want more
I cannot wait for the second series
you know what though after the first
episode you ever have these these series
that you think the first episode goes by
and thinking I'm not sure
um I didn't like the guy playing the
Sandman he didn't say anything for the
like three episodes
um and I thought I'd start I don't like
I don't like the actor and like I wasn't
quite feeling it but by like episode
four
I was just like and by the end of it
I'm desperate for more it's our
brilliant show a bit of a slow burn at
first but my God it was a good show
one of them shows because I listened to
audio books on Audible
the the second book is on Audible and
I've really considered listening to it
because I know I'm gonna have to wait a
really long time for Spider-Man season
two so I might I might just listen to it
because I really want it that much
it's gonna move away from the comics
there's nothing for the second series
the the
um showrunner said so it's quite it was
quite strictly on the comic book series
for the first one
um it's going into you know the whole
thing with Satan at the end and that
that storyline where it ended it's going
to be going into more that so it's going
to be inspired by but not quite as
strict on the comic books
um the showrunner Basics says is is he
felt at times
um the story was a bit jerky because it
was so strict on they really wanted to
do something that was quite close to the
comic so
um
yeah I'd think Bob's just made a point
there did you guys watch night sky no I
was I was is that the one with uh Josh
Brolin on Amazon Prime yeah yeah so I
mean this is a show that's that's
required a little bit of thought to get
into and I actually think it would have
made a good movie rather than a series
um
but
I agree with Bob there I had promise
[Music]
um
I I I would have liked more from it but
I think what we got from it if you go
guys give it a watch at some points I
don't think it matters too much it was
canceled
um from a whole point you're not left on
a big Cliffhanger or anything I don't
think too much
um it's not like I watched something
like called the fog a few years ago and
they did one season it was really
getting good and then they canceled it
but it was just like no that they're all
trapped in a house killing each other
the love of God
um it's not like one of those shows that
you can watch it and just enjoy it for
what it what it was you know what it is
something but I don't think they're
going to have a second series last time
I heard I think it's been canceled
um but you never know nowadays [ __ ] gets
canceled all the time and then comes
back anyway this is like we have loads
of zombie TV series it doesn't matter
how many times they get canceled they
just come back but
um
so how about how about you what sort of
what's really surprised you this year
what surprised me I guess
um wanting more though was I if I'm
going TV I'm going Sandman as well I
just I have to I had never read the
comics or anything like that before I'm
just a fan of Neil Gaiman in general so
watching that was awesome and if he
still heavily involved with season two
don't screw the comments I know he's
he's Loosely followed but as long as
Neil gaiman's there I'm a happy freaking
camper and I think the point to what is
what he was trying to say was he's
they're just going to make you notice
like Books and Comics and things you
can't strictly turn it into TV shows
then
um they're just different genres they
don't work and this is the elements of
the first series didn't work because
they they really had this conscious
effort to be strict and this actually we
need to make a TV show I think was his
point so this they're gonna have to move
away a little bit so they can make a TV
show
um but but yeah let's see what happens
um
real quick
[Laughter]
I'm with you Shelly I'm with you when it
comes to movies
you know I think as soon as a movie gets
like nominated for best film at the
Oscars I'm like I ain't watching that
because I'm gonna have to think about it
[Music]
um
I don't want to think oh that's about
popcorn
um for me the biggest surprise because
it was a series that I genuinely assumed
I would hate because I detested the
movie it spun off from
um it it was awful
um but Peacemaker I absolutely adored
that series
was amazing the opening credits oh that
song I absolutely love it yeah I just I
just I loved everything about that
series
um I actually thought it was really good
I thought it was funny I thought the
story was actually pretty good I thought
the characters were great I know it was
more of a comedy than anything else but
the main thing that surprised me that I
enjoyed it so much is because I'm not a
massive fan of John Cena even though
I've seen him he did his thing film
called a few years ago called six rounds
and it was actually brilliant in
um but I'm not a huge fan of that I'm
not a huge fan of wrestlers becoming
movie stars the rock is the exception
um
but
um I just but I hated both of the movies
that it like spun off from so much
that um I didn't expect isn't that I
didn't expect to love it and I just did
yeah I didn't what I didn't watch
Suicide Squad because the first Suicide
Squad was awful so I never watched it
but having seen The Peacemaker TV show I
actually want to see it now no don't
don't it's better than the first one no
it isn't it
it's much worse and for me anyway so you
know we express our opinions here and
everyone's opinion is valid
um mostly mine but everyone's opinion
I've got the power to kick out I don't
go now because Matt's got so do I
oh my power
but um but now everything
Peacemaker is awful in the background
and from the rooftops from from as far
away as possible oh no pink snake is 100
one of those shows that you either love
or hate and and I completely get that
um
so if there was a show that I did not
want to finish that I finished this year
was Peacemaker because I was banging my
head against the table every episode but
I was like
yeah I've started now and I all finished
damn it that was this your suit opening
something that I think makes a really
good TV show is a really good soundtrack
to go with it and Peacemaker had a
fantastic
actually like by the end of it I really
cared about and I just I just thought it
was great and um and obviously um as
Robert Patrick as his dad was just okay
um there's a series of views because
they did um a spin-off show from um I'm
gonna forget what's called
um
let's give me some uh speaking with
yourself I'll be back in a second
um
but anyway there's a TV show that was
similar and it had
um
the fall guy who played The Fall Guy
Ryan Reynolds now the original for the
series in the 60s
Lee Majors right Lee Majors played his
dad and it was uh the Living Dead from
the living dead it was a series Without
um and they did a TV series and it was
just brilliant and Lee Majors was his
dad and he ends up running over his dad
in a car and prescription his brain it's
just us glorious but anyway
um right so
actually I'm sorry I have one of those
things you ever thought and you can't
get it out your head but you can't have
words that go with the thought but
anyway we'll move on so
what have you binged this year so what
did you start watching and then you just
went I must watch the next episode
immediately and stay to up till three
o'clock in the morning watching all of
these now
stormy's not with us again but for me I
know stormy's answer would have been
um the living dead he watched one
episode because he thought walking of
the Living Dead
um he watched one episode and he ended
up staying at four in the morning
watching the rest
walking up the living dead as a new one
The Walking Dead
I never watched it
never watched my mother was born
where I'm coming from no it
on comic books The Walking Dead by uh
Robert Kirkman the guy that also does
invincible for Amazon Prime and all that
those comics and all that
yes I love the start of it because I
like the main actor in the first season
so the British guy that's now I don't
know his name but um well I started to
watch it because of him and then I just
realized zombies are stupid and stop
watching so yeah um how about you guys
though what what what have you binged
this year
I binged
uh I don't know when it was probably
sometimes towards the beginning of this
year
Better Call Saul
my best friend had basically told me I
I've watched Breaking Bad like five
times over it's one of my favorite TV
shows of all time
I did start watching back also a few
years ago and then couldn't get into it
because the first season's really slow
so I never finished it but my best mate
basically messaged me again I did this
the last season of uh Better Call Saul
uh and it's really it's really really
good so I'm like okay I'll watch it I
finished season one and after season one
it gets so good and I literally binged
Five Seasons in about two weeks
and then that's away about a month maybe
two months I can't remember how long it
was in for season six to come out and
then binged all of that in about two or
three days oh absolutely it's fantastic
if you've never seen if you if you watch
Breaking Bad
Better Call Saul is better than Breaking
Bad
that's what I've heard yes
I've heard it I mean Bob Odenkirk is
just fan freaking tastic but yeah did
you see him in nobody yeah
almost forget about it it surprised you
but I saw that and soon so that's it's
John Wick but with a this is a tin type
I love that movie it's a proper nature
it was made by Chad stachelski the guy
that wrote John Wick and directed the
first one
[Music]
and then he doesn't and he gets thrown
off the bus and then he gets back on
yeah try again try again oh it's just uh
you know such a clever movie from
beginning to end a really clever movie
but acted so well it's absolutely
brilliant but be Harris what what have
you binged
other than Stargate which we know you've
been binging I was about to say I've
binged a hell of a lot of Stargate this
year but the only other thing that I
think I've really
binged binged was
I I binged cuphead when it came out just
because I love animation like that and
that and Netflix does a great little
cuphead show and those are like 15 20
minute episodes but the only thing I've
really binged binge besides that was
the one or I guess the two things
technically that I have to binge every
single year is Avatar The Last Airbender
and The Legend of Korra and you know and
I have to it was my yearlies
oh
I take that back at the very beginning
of the year I I did binge Ben 10 as well
because I just binged those two shows
and I was like I want another good kid
show that I really liked when I was
younger that's that's actually fun so I
went Ben 10 little Omnitrix over there
you know I I did a similar to I binged
the human cartoon series with Kevin
Smith I waited for them all to come out
and then I binged it but partly because
I have covered so I was off for a few
days and partly because I knew I was
gonna probably hate it so I thought I've
just got to get through it just like rip
the Band-Aid off and get for it and I I
had a love hate relationship but we're
getting the second series of the Masters
of the Universe and I did have a
love-hate relationship with it but I got
a love-hate relationship with most of
what Kevin Smith does so Dogma yeah the
greatest movies I've ever seen I love
that movie
um
almost everything else he's done since
not so much
and you can not watch dogs anywhere you
can't watch it nothing no streaming
service nothing
completely gone oh incident's gone he's
back again what are you going to say
about something all right I was going to
ask Harris a question but he's a he's
sorry I've got a sleeping person behind
me that's going to the spa in 10 minutes
I was just making sure she'd be ready to
go to school of course I was gonna ask
did you you said you like watching
cartoons
on Netflix it's my job
the what Inside Job
yeah it's very good it's very funny it's
it's it's it's it's
I don't know how to explain it it's just
stupid humor but it's really good it's
really good yes sir I'm not mixed up
with the same thing it's like the Men in
Black type thing yeah
she works for the government because the
gov essentially the whole conspiracy of
the world is run by uh Shadow cabal
that's true in this universe and she
works for them it's basically work for
the company that sort of works it's like
a corporation yeah yeah
um it's it's
ridiculous in its stupidity but it's
proper like
um airplane humor it's that sort of
thing and really stupid
the guy who plays that is the guy from
stranger things you know the the guy who
pretends to be Russian
oh okay that's his voice I started
watching it I'm like I know that voice
from somewhere
uh I don't know if he was in Game of
Thrones was he
yeah he played not uh uh
uh I almost said Dario no Harris that's
not it he played uh
uh the dude that trains Arya he he I
can't think of the guy's name uh it's a
j j I do know who you mean though
it's on the tip of my tongue but he he's
the guy that did Russian and stranger
things excellent in everything I've ever
seen him
that's what I think what happens here
I've been stranger things
I held off
um the first part I've binged the first
half
um but then the other the second half
there were quite long episodes in there
so I couldn't really do that but um and
I was just so desperate to watch it by
the second half
um that's also going to be on my list in
a second we talk about what you're
desperately waiting for more of
course I've got to wait like two years
or something but I can't wait for that
that's the guy's name Brett Gelman is
the guy
um I'll try to think what else I've
binged I've started watching um a show
called Boston Legal which you guys I
don't think you guys have ever heard of
um but I'm binging at the moment I'm
already like I only started like two
weeks ago I didn't like the third series
I've suddenly realized because of the
channel I actually do need to watch
science fiction and like and I've just
been watching Boston playing God's dead
so I'm just like I can't really talk
about this on the channel but hey I'm
going to anyway
um but the science fiction connection
though is James Spader and
um
star in it
um and it's a legal comedy drama written
by David E Kelly so if you like you know
like procedural
um TV shows like that you'll absolutely
adore and obviously the acting is
brilliant they really tackle some proper
issues in a lot of the court cases they
do
um and William shatness has got mad cow
disease and he keeps saying Lock and
Load and shooting people quite regularly
so I mean the whole basically the part
of the thing is that William Shatner is
the greatest living lawyer that is the
greatest lawyer that's ever lived sort
of thing he's never lost a case but he's
got Alzheimer's
um or or as you miss so he's starting to
lose his faculties
um but then he hears about mad cow
disease and now then he's just time zone
I've got my camera all the way through
so um yeah now Boston Legal is one of my
favorite TV shows and I've I found it on
Disney because it was an old foxter so
I've started watching it again
um but they've just had an episode
actually where they slag Fox off all the
way through because there's a teacher
that's banned Fox News from the school
and they just keep going on and on about
how crap Fox News is and how biased it
is and everything else and they keep
like a little digs because they're
actually on the Fox network that's who
makes the show it's just art it's just
fantastic but um
I did watch um I did watch a show with
James Spader quite recently but then I
need to watch more of it the Blacklist
that was pretty good
yeah blacklisters Blacklist after about
the third season it went off the wall
for me but that's one of those shows
that the first season was beyond
brilliant the first season was so good
um and then it got a bit it didn't I
don't think they quite knew how to
do it after the first season it's a bit
like Fringe throughout the first season
was beyond fantastic and then they they
kind of thought oh [ __ ] we didn't think
it was going to be this popular
[Music]
um
yeah don't get me started off Fringe
um I love the show where they're just
sort of like oh crap people are watching
this we're gonna have to actually think
what to do with the second series
um uh I'll tell you what show that was
really like that what was the TV show
that um it started with uh she was in a
bag in Times Square and she lost her
memory
oh yeah
um I see that they're memory wiped it
was the biggest show on telly the first
season and it is that's why it's bugging
me I can't think I was 12.
um it had the guy from somebody getting
the comments please and help us out
um the other guy that starred in it was
actually in a British soldier show over
here oh what was it called
um oh I'll tell you what it was the
actress that played uh
what's that blind spot blind spot blind
spot thank you the first season was
fantastic
um and it was a really really cool
um story idea
um but they painted themselves into a
corner and you could tell by about the
third season they were like oh [ __ ] but
it actually ended really strong but the
third season was like
why am I still watching this
um because I need to know what happened
um but blind spot was you know they
definitely paint themselves into a
corner in that show but yeah it was the
it was the most highly rated show on TV
in its first season fantastic
um but yeah so yeah I haven't binged a
great deal this year which is weird
because I mean lots of streaming
services though they've stopped dumping
everything they want hitting there
they've gone back to sort of like once a
week
yeah they don't drop things anymore
I prefer it when they drop it all at
once though because I can binge you I
like binge and we've had this discussion
before but I prefer binging to wait in
every week I don't have the patience
um yeah if you like everything
everywhere all at once
which that that's got to be my most
that's my favorite film of the Year
still is I love it that's my
um probably the film that surprised me
the most I know I know Michelle yeah is
awesome so I was expecting it to be good
and then I went and I watched it and I
did come away going
how many times have you ever watched a
movie back to back you've watched a
movie then rewind a bit and watched it
again well you haven't rewound it
because that's from my era when I had to
rewind the film but I often I I watched
twice straight away I watched it once
and I watched it again I've only ever
put it five times in theaters maybe six
I loved it yeah
for many years since you're a kid sort
of thing
yeah I remember I used to do it with
white chicks
[Music]
I love that film so I used to literally
watch it on repeat when I was little
that won't quitting all over it
um I've never done that but then but
yeah I've only ever done it three or
four times in my life but um but but
yeah I did it with that Moulin Rouge is
one of the other films I did it with a
watch movie on Rouge and then I
immediately don't know why
um Midnight Club Rodrigo yeah that was
and Dave that was great it's really
really good I really enjoyed him in that
club
um start on my list
um
so
um okay we're gonna get into the the
loaded question though so what
disappointed you
the most this year
manifest
that supported me as well I didn't watch
it
um I can't I can't I can't even think of
anything else that I've watched as
disappointed me as much as Manifest even
though I knew going into it it was going
to be disappointing
I was I was even more disappointed than
what I expected to be wow that's pretty
disappointing
expecting it to be rubbish and then you
come away disappointed that's pretty bad
so
like really disappointed
don't kill me everybody but I cannot
stand the Batman that was three hours of
shite that that was that was no
no
I can't do it I don't want more I don't
the only thing that I can stand in that
movie is Colin Farrell as penguin and
besides that toss it bye I like Andy
Circus but
he was an Alfred and besides that I mean
uh do you know what the note I've put
next to the Batman because it is on my
list is too long but loved it
but Batman's my favorite character but
it was too oh I I Adore Batman and
that's why I didn't like it that much is
because I you you have so much to pull
from and and who's who's the villain is
it is it penguin is it of course it's
Riddler and it's also Carmine Falcone
but give Carmine Falcon his own movie do
the Riddler next do the Riddler down the
road don't toss the Joker in here did
why did we need Zoe Kravitz as Catwoman
she didn't play a really big part in the
film at all I it was just too much with
too little there wasn't Soul there was
Zero soul of that movie and if the movie
doesn't have soul I can't watch it I
think if they do directors could it'd be
two 90-minute movies
and and that hurt me the most because I
absolutely adore Matt Reeves that's I
love the director fantastic director I
say I loved it but it's in I loved bits
of it and that is the problem and I
loved what they were trying to do with
it
um but I I do know what you mean it was
too long and there's
there was something missing from it I'll
give you that and I I can't quite put my
finger on what it was but there was
something missing from it and so
just saying that last sentence there
about loving the director but not being
able to stand the film itself I had I
didn't like the film so much that I
shoved it out of my memory banks for a
little bit
and then there's Thor love and Thunder
is the film that probably disappointed
me the most this season this year
um because I was so excited by it and it
looked really great from the adverts and
I loved Ragnarok Ragnarok to me was just
it's it's top three best Marvel movies
for me I adored that movie it's saved
Thor as a character but in a way I wish
it had 100 because we got love and
Thunder
um Lovington there was part of my French
a complete [ __ ] show from beginning to
end
um it may be
the worst Marvel movie that they've made
and considering a couple of the films
they've done recently that same quite a
lot yeah see I I haven't seen
I've not seen the new Thor film but the
the I was gonna say
uh if in terms of films this year the
one that disappointed me most was Dr
Strange
Doctor Strange too is is is pretty bad
as well yeah um black widow I didn't
hate it's just a bit forgettable
it's a bit of a blur there was nothing
in there to dislike
but there was nothing massively in there
to love either and to be honest I'd
struggle telling you what the plot was
there wasn't one there was no soul on
that movie I um
I think Marvel has lost its solo isn't
it I think they've definitely lost their
way they don't know what they're doing
at the moment and they they had all the
chance to bring it back with well okay
werewolf by night had a little bit of
soul to it but I think that's just
Michael giacino the the director
composer of course and he the composer
not being able to bring soul to
something come on okay of course he was
gonna do that but black panther 2 was
where as a brand as a as a company
it felt like it could have brought back
that soul back the the Necessities that
the MCU needs to make it feel actually
pivotal and not just third act CGI
screwing around kind of stuff you know
but
and that's my problem with them
with black panther was supposed to be
their
Flagship movie this year
because of how much
they knew they were going to make a
crapload of money there was so much we
were looking for this movie so much so I
wondered did they just pull resources
from Doctor Strange 2 and
um you know and love and thunder maybe
well we've we've discussed it repeatedly
and we the special effects are seriously
dodgy in places
um and but maybe they'd shift the
resources to Black Panther and that they
were making a lot of movies because
um you know we've had three or four
Marvel movies this year because of kovid
and so they're trying to catch up
um but then I watched black panther I'm
like no they haven't they didn't shift
it some of those special effects in this
are seriously dodgy
um and you know it's like 10 years ago
sort of effect you know I'm like
it's it just feels to me like it's
quantity over quality at the moment with
Marvel
what proves that even more and is almost
a slap in the face it's meta and it is
funny to a degree to a degree because
I'll recognize it is is the last episode
of She-Hulk literally the little Kevin
machines like turn around we're not
gonna have you transform on screen
because it saves US money it's like okay
yes that's funny to a degree it's meta
but what are we all watching this for
we're not watching it for this you know
that's that's not the point why a single
soul came to
press play nobody wanted to see that
that's the exact opposite not just
tonally of what we want to see but what
we like plot wise what we want to see
and it's just kind of it's
representative of the rest of the MCU
right now it's just kind of it's lacking
that Soul like there's there's no reason
to be doing it at this point besides
the show I've got down for me for the
most that disappointed me the most I've
got two actually but the one that
disappoint me the most was Moon Knight
now I know somebody
quite liked me like
but I was really disappointed but I was
disappointed by because that was the
first time I actually genuinely remember
going
this is Marvel and I really don't like
it and you know it's like and then since
then but I think She-Hulk is is worse
but I was ready for it by then I was at
my expectations had been lowered by 12
months of crap from Marvel
Moon night really disappointed me
because it's probably the first thing
Marvel did that I've literally gone
that's just bad
and I don't understand and I didn't
understand it and I'm saying to you how
strong I remember at one point I sort of
got distracted but I was talking and I
was looking over here like I look back
and I was hippo talking and so like what
a bloody hell is going on now
um and and I just by the end of it I was
just like I don't know what's going on I
don't know who's who
um and to be honest I don't care
you must want to know you had to pay
attention otherwise you'd missed
something important
because I just I just I didn't get it it
just didn't well the only other thing is
the show literally
purposely Cuts away at pivotal important
moments and you just instead of like yes
it makes sense with the whole uh
associative disidentity disorder all
that good stuff but
you're cutting away from your major plot
points what's I I just I don't
understand the the reasoning behind that
especially if you want to make [ __ ]
money excuse me excuse the French again
but if you want to make some money like
show us the plot points you know like
yeah
um exactly a 100 on that one and I think
She-Hulk sort of suffer from the same
thing that if they'd have the first
episode of moon night was Bloody
brilliant it was so good I was coming
away from the gun that's so clever but
the problem is they kept doing it
and She-Hulk the first time they did the
little meta jokes I'm like oh that's
very good brilliant but then they kept
do we need and I was like by the end of
this series it's just like I don't know
what's going on
the fourth wall meta breaking is perfect
but to and I I do like the concept of
breaking the fourth wall for an episode
of something but that shouldn't be I
maybe second or third or fourth season
if it does that like at the end of the
first season you need something
grounding there was there was nothing
grounding about the entire series at all
and then to go that meta just
it just got Beyond confusing
um yeah the last night was excellent by
the way
um
but you you said disappointing shows
yeah
um but but yeah moonlight moonlight was
saying I know okay I'm gonna throw
Catwoman's pigeons here a little bit I
think but the other show I've got listed
for my disappointed me
Obi-Wan Kenobi
well I thought I thought you're right I
thought that was your reaction I thought
I might get I found it boring
oh no no I I completely agree I that's
same with Thor love and thunder I didn't
even that I I that was in like the
recesses of my brain it was gone I've I
can't um
it did have boring elements I agree but
when it when it was good it was
fantastic and I think that makes up for
the boring elements of it in the first
and the last episode
okay
that was the best part that's a battle
that the later battle in in
chronologically speaking should have
been I said to you at the time tonight I
saw him something on YouTube and they'd
redone the Obi-Wan Kenobi Darth Vader
battle from A New Hope but doing like
pulling stuff in and going [ __ ] crazy
with it and and you know because
obviously it's a completely different
time and you know they didn't like there
was no way they could have done a fight
like the weekend now but the Obi-Wan
fight with Darth was was cool
um
Obi-Wan all the way through
again though now I can't actually tell
you much about the plot I can't I can't
remember it because the Middle episodes
repeat themselves three times over yes
it's it could it I'd warned Beatty the
right the original writer who wrote it
for film not television
lays out everything perfectly and it's
just like yeah it should have been a
movie but of course Disney and uh
Kathleen Kennedy were too scared to
release it as a film right now and
come on Star Wars need to Star Wars
needs a movie
I think it would have done fantastic as
a movie
it would have it would have played a lot
better like it would have been awesome
as a movie it was supposed to be at the
beginning of a Trilogy and now they
might not even get a second season
have they officially announced one I
don't I don't think they work in the
second season but I'm um
I think they said they were they were
aiming to
yeah I I know you and McGregor is like
pushing for one but
[Music]
the problem I can see with another
season of Obi-Wan is what what is what
happened in between that battle and then
the final battle between Vader him and
Vader like what what actually happened
that's actually worth telling because he
was a Hermit for all the types of
purposes as far as we know yeah and
where else could it go without
legitimately screwing up Canon and yeah
sure you don't need to like stick to
Canon like super super super hardcore
all the time but don't destroy the
original film because of
it's fine because it it gives you a
little bit more context in between the
the
uh prequels and the the original
original films too
the layer stuff is my favorite I think
at the end of the day coming out of it
him
explains how she knows him and why she's
asking for his help
um
but beyond that I don't I don't think
there needs to be any more story with
him really
nothing official on a series season two
but they do keep talking about it and
they were talking about it it seems
about a month ago
um but but yeah so I'm nothing official
but they've just read a little bit there
about the director he says the director
is saying like look everyone's shouting
for season two and Disney would like a
season two but it was always written and
set up to be a one-off
Limited
thing and where Obi-Wan's Now sort of
gone back to I love saying this I think
there's an easy story because Obi-Wan's
gone back
into the desert too positive
to like
we still need to understand why you
became a Hermit and why why he how does
he go from that character to the
character we see at the start a new hope
um but to me that's going to be quite a
depressing series because we're gonna
have to basically see his will get
smashed again yeah
in a way it would have been better if
they happened to made it because
at the end of you know the uh whatever
the third bad Trilogy film who he was in
when he cuts thingy's legs off and Cooks
him in the volcano
um at the end of that series his will
was broken this series he we started off
with his will broken but he like became
positive again towards the end and got
some hope back and then by the start of
new hope he's gonna have his will broken
again
but and then I I also just have issues
with Liam Neeson coming back as an
actual Force ghost as much as I adore
Liam Neeson and I I do want him back to
a degree
are we getting another George Lucas
released
thing where like Hayden's uh Christensen
is playing Darth Vader and like the
Return of the Jedi scene where
everyone's dancing around as a force
ghost but now Liam Neeson's at it on
there because the whole point was that
Liam Neeson wasn't
he's the one who taught Yoda how to do
that in the first place
and Obi-Wan etc etc like it just it
hurts me but one sec the one thing
that's America
that's America's ass I was requested to
say that a couple times I just want to
make sure
[Laughter]
that is the one thing that did annoy me
about Obi-Wan was
they didn't use the same technology to
de-age
um Anakin he did not look he was the 40
year old Padawan like there was that
Meme going around like they did though
they did though and they stopped halfway
through the job
if that was their attempt at doing it
that was [ __ ] engaged
oh God
all right well as anything else
seriously disappointed you guys this
season before we move on
um I think I've covered most of mine
oh well Matt did make mention something
right prior to the stream where your
disappointment was Moon Knight his was
can you remember Paramount Plus
Paramount Plus
Halo
Halo oh yes Halo Halo [ __ ] yeah that was
[ __ ] I actually hated it absolutely
hated it oh I watched like the first day
two or three episodes
I tried to get into it because I do like
Halo and it just was not good
oh I can't even explain why I didn't
like it it just it just like this the
effects and stuff fine it looked like a
Indigo in the trailer like it looked
like it was going to be amazing but it
just wasn't and I don't quite know what
was what I didn't like but I just didn't
like it
one of my
I enjoyed it as well one of my friends
that watched it like alongside me is a
big big halo person I never played Halo
I played Halo Reach was the only game I
ever played but he hated it because he
he wanted to see
uh the this the silver team I think is
Halo team and this is blue team it's
like def technically a different
Multiverse or a different universe or
something yeah uh and it was it was just
too
he thought they were adapting I guess
and they're they're not but they are ish
I'm not entirely sure honestly well
they've got to go somewhere else and
they've got something to hold back for
the second series and whatever they want
as well so they've got together they've
got somewhere to go
um I I really enjoyed it
but I I was thinking about this after
you said
um earlier I can kind of understand why
you'd hate it because I actually
generally think the second and third
episode I thought it started really
strongly and I thought it ended really
strongly but there was a bit of them in
the Middle where it did lack and it was
a bit hard going
um so I can kind of understand why
you'd lose interest and but I I say I
really enjoyed it I'm looking forward to
the second season I think that'd be
great yeah I just don't think I honestly
don't think they should make TV shows
out of games
I just don't think it works
if they're gonna do it it needs to be
sort of like inspired by again talking
about how Books and Comics and things
don't always translate into movies great
and you can't do a strict I'm just
saying it's why the Harry Potters the
end of the Harry Potter's movies sort of
go hmm and sort of fizzle out because
they kept it quite reasonably strict to
the book and they cut a lot out
obviously but reason through the book
and that's how books work they sort of
do an epilogue sort of thing where
movies don't they tend to end on a end
um you know
um but I'm with you I think inspired by
is fine you know because I got some
really cool stuff but hey look we're
gonna have to put up a Super Mario
Brothers soon and and that might be a
poke in the eye and I hate this movie
moment are they seriously making that
into a film it's been made have you not
seen the trailer I I actually think
that's gonna be great everyone's so mad
about Chris Pratt but I think it's gonna
be excellent and everyone in Italy is
excited about it so something's got to
be right I'm just it's the trailer over
there the voice is Italian probably no I
still people the American Trailer
has done it but he's just done it his
voice if there's no Luigi there's none
of that he's just gone hey Luigi you're
right mate and it's it's
I don't know
the trailer without without Mario in is
quite cool I like it when the crop comes
down I like it attack and they all throw
the snowballs at him and they're just
going
and then let's go and everyone explodes
yeah it might be right hey when I when
Sonic came out I thought that was going
to be awful and actually the Sonic movie
is great but it is it should be called
the Jim Carrey movie
in this one Jack Black is Bowser he's
gotta take the cake here I mean
and this might actually be all right
because it's a cut it's cartonized
cartoonized it's not like it's not it's
not live action if it was live action
that's that's what my fear was like
Sonic
yeah but I mean I actually really
enjoyed Sonic I really enjoyed both
Sonic movies but I might I I've um you
know I was saying oh you're supposed to
be in touch with your inner child mine's
firmly in the driving seat and it's um
and am I in a child goes what's that and
I'm like that that was the part of me
that when Pikachu came out I went to the
cinema to watch it
um you know it's like obviously because
Ryan Reynolds was in it as well and I
love Ryan Reynolds but
um but yeah I might think so right so
guys let's talk movies really really
quickly so there are there any movies
that you've seen this season that that
you've just thought that's that's a
standout that is effing brilliant and I
I I'm gonna throw the ball out there
first one I think genuinely the best
sci-fi movie of this season of this year
so far sorry has been nope
I thought that was
true proper sci-fi I know it's a little
bit of horror in there as well but
proper sci-fi movie I think it's
probably the only really that I would
say like proper sci-fi film of the year
but what do you guys think is there
anything that stood out like that you
just think that was just respect to it
sort of thing
I mean in a Sci-Fi sense
because I generally thought it was just
phenomenal
yeah no in a Sci-Fi sense I'd say Vesper
in a way just because it's it's not like
giant it's not a big movie it's not it's
not really a thousand percent grasping
or anything but from someone who wants
to be a filmmaker and just adore sci-fi
that's how you do it with with the low
budget and that that that's inspiring I
guess in in that sense
what film have you respected this year
so that's perfect example yeah there's
there's been a bunch uh the
the northmen we've talked a little bit
about that is something that I want more
of but I there's no way you get more of
it's essentially just the story of
Hamlet but it's amless you know it's
just the original story and uh that's
just
excellently made in every sense of the
word
yeah how about you
um that's anything jumping into your
mind doesn't matter if it doesn't I just
I mean the only real film that I've
watched that's even so much relates that
related to science sci-fi it's the atom
project
and it's a Kids film but I actually
quite enjoyed it it was quite good
I don't think that sort of film doesn't
have to be big it doesn't have to be
clever it's just got to tell a story in
that film to me with Adam product was
just like uh we've got this we've got
this basic plot it's not it's not you
know it's not breaking any molds and
we've got these cool sort of weapons we
might sell some toys and Ryan Reynolds
is in it and they just sort of went yeah
okay and they just did that is the Hulk
his dad is the Hulk
now and the kid that's in it is
brilliant and uh what was the movie he's
going to be doing he's going to be doing
something brilliant I think he's going
to be in the Netflix
absolutely
heavily involved thankfully the author
yeah yeah it's going to be phenomenal
but yeah there's there is rumors that
there's never any story and he'll be in
that as well
um but I think they were just watching
that
yeah
there's a list of films
[Music]
they don't need to do that they don't
need to do fly to the Navigator and they
don't need to do big big little China
and the chances are they're going to do
all three
um no there's not necessary it's just
just [ __ ] some films just don't need to
be remade Challenge in a chocolate
factory they didn't need to be remake
that film and look at the absolute
poop fast they did and after they did it
with Johnny Depp they've done it again
they've done another Charlie in the
Chocolate Bar
streaming serious
ly have they you know they're the
prequel that they're filming right now
right
the prequel sorry isn't it yeah that's
the movie that yeah
it's just just just don't do it but
anyway
so um I would also throw in topical
Maverick and that genre talking about
films that just it's just
what it says on the tin
it's not Wonka you're talking about
Wonka something like that they're called
Wonka it doesn't need to be done yeah
that's not um a film you want to have a
couple of pints and then go and order
the tickets for is it and what did you
call me you're gonna end up having a
fight with me
um but yeah top gun Maverick again not
nothing big nothing clever they didn't
re reinvent the wheel they just did
absolutely phenomenal really
um
Beast with interest Albert as well
before we go on to the left yes
great
there were a couple other just fantastic
films that came out through the year
what matters
uh but have you all seen banshees even a
Sharon yet
no but my mom and dad
that might be the best time of the year
it's so good it is so so well made and
it's it's just accidentally acted
Etc
yeah but uh if you want socks with that
logo on
you can't have them so I didn't put
socks on when I did this logo but
everything else
um if you want this you can't have it
you can't have it unless you beg me and
then I suppose I could I don't think it
would look right on stocks actually but
this design if now Side District are
calm
um buy stuff because then
um I'll be allowed to continue to do the
show because my wife will let me my
wife's very happy it makes a wonderful
Black Friday and Christmas gifts oh yes
and this design actually get 10 off at
the moment if you get on there quick
so
um right the last question of the
evening before we Tulu and you go back
to your Italian adventure and Matt goes
back to um
living in a box probably is it that way
you do under a bridge or something
um and I'd probably go make tea
um
shut up man uh the last question of the
day is what are you desperately after
watching this year what are you
desperately waiting for more of we've
we've touched on this a little bit but
what other shows that you're thinking I
can't wait for the the sequel or the
next bit or whatever
all day
Mandalorian and that comes out next year
is it next year was it year after it's
next year yeah I don't think we've had a
Mandalorian this year if we put Boba
Fett and I would I would say Mandalorian
these series are all intertwined aren't
they so they're all like yeah
uh now look
um
I mean manifest next year just because I
need to finish it but I'm not looking
forward to it
foreign
yeah okay
how about you guys what you what are
your desk before next next year
TV show wise
just I I know it's not coming next year
but I just I need more House of the
dragon and I need more Andor
just you know quickly give me all of it
more
Doctor Who Doctor Who's on next [ __ ]
with David Tennant with David Tennant
yes very much I'm looking forward to
that and yes I I will be excited about
that I've not been excited about Doctor
Who for about five years so that that I
will watch and for me
um Strange New World for the second
season it thanks soon actually I think I
don't even have to wait till next year
um but strange New World saved Star Trek
as far as I'm concerned
um I've done I've not liked everything
else I've like um Discovery and so
strange new worlds oh yes
um
and so I'm not getting stranger things
next year either but I'm desperate for
more strange things I really really want
that to it it's not next year
I don't think it is
I know it took them a long time to make
the last season that's just because it
was covered related
yeah
this is going to take some time yeah
it's all the actors getting all the
actors maybe mainly Bobby trying to get
her she's busy lady
um I would say the next June which I
don't think that's next year either is
it but the next June I love the June
movie uh oh actually I'm really looking
for theorist actually as well that's
going to be on HBO Max next year
um so that would be really good
um
a couple of really quick uh movies
though that I have enjoyed this year
that I forgot about that on my list
bullet train with Brad Pitt was Bloody
brilliant again not a massive just
really like character Driven movie
um but fantastic and you know we talk
about rom-coms I'm see I'm a secret
rom-com lover I'm a secret rhyme combo
um I loved
um what's it called ticket to Paradise
with George Clooney and um and uh Julie
Roberts I watched it a couple of weeks
ago
it's just a perfect movie
and it's just it's just lovely you just
come we're going oh that's a nice movie
um
it's just it's just a really sweet fan
and uh one of those heart groups three
times it does occasionally and then it
swivels back up into a black
um uh but another thing that
disappointed the crap out of me this
season and this year's Zone it shouldn't
have done was the man who felt worth
um and I watched that because I was a
massive fan of the original movie and
um you know I I thought it was going to
be great and it just wasn't
I found it incredibly boring
and that's
that's it that's where we're at but
Mandalorian 100 percent
Mandalorian and Ahsoka next year those
take my place for uh the the Andor and
Hot D over there
yeah yeah
honestly
Star Wars
could do no wrong for me on the TV at
the moment
other than
what and hook a bow with that too though
I mean but it's it's more mid compared
to just Obi-Wan probably on Booker Bob
affair
but those those two episodes he's not in
oh they're all right
give me Mandalorian season 2.5 or 1.5
whatever it was uh the Mandalorian when
mandolin took over and the whole thing
with um uh oh God the actor's name you
know the um
the cowboy in the village and he was
shot yeah
um Timothy Olyphant
um I think Tim he's his own series
I just think I think I love the accent I
think he's great and I just
he's fantastic
he was really good in the Santa Clara
Santa Clarita project yeah that was
really good yeah I love downstairs
that's supposed to be coming back from
another series as well and it's been
like three years since it was on the
screen was it Drew Barrymore right
it's just it's a weird show it's like a
weird premise but it's actually pretty
good it's it's cannibalism right isn't
it based around like the meeting people
essentially yeah and she has to eat eat
things to stay alive but if you've
watched a zombie that's a similar I was
on the CW wasn't it years ago similar
sort of premise it was actually quite
good
um it's funny because she like kills the
neighbor
and it's just his hand in the garden and
he is the bloke walks in he just sees
the hand because what did you do yeah
what did you do
Timothy Olyphant fix goal it's Justified
it's just
brilliant television and you'll
recognize you know when it's a great TV
show and you've got all these actors
that really go oh I know him from that
other thing that he was in after and
it's because yeah he's just putting
putting a TV show but guys right so that
was
our look back at 2022.
um thank you very much for joining as
always
um I think maybe next week we will have
a little bit of a chat about what we're
looking forward to over the Christmas
period as we're coming into Christmas
um so we'll have a bit of a jingle bells
jingle bells
um week
um but not just that what we're looking
forward to early next year as well
um so we'll have a look at that and just
anything else you guys want to talk
about in the comments as always so thank
you so much say bye Matt
bye-bye Matt
every week I say that and I say shut up
Matt when are you gonna learn
when
are you good at I'm not going to shut up
to be fair it would be slightly crap if
you did
all right
foreign
yes you can tell but every time you move
your head in a big massive lump of the
wall appears here's my actual green
screen
I'm like screwing your teeth out there
but anyway
our Young Americans so saved by house
that's America's ass
for Shelly and Mark in there
uh we love it Italy are you gonna be
back in California next week or are you
still going to be in Italy
uh I I'm leaving Italy tomorrow morning
but I will be in Texas I I might be back
in California by Sunday I'm not positive
I I gotta actually check on that
one of the two
that'd be great we'll have all the
gunshots in the background
guys thank you so so much as always it's
been emotional
um hopefully we'll get stormy back at
some point but he he's working really
really hard but he I'm sure he wants to
come back as soon as he can but in the
meantime
bye everybody see you soon
bye
[Music]